les pigeons à 62 ans elle est atteinte
de sclérose en plaques d'arthrite
rhumatoïde
elle est aussi épileptique pas de
conjoint pas d'enfant elle vit seule
dans cet appartement de rosemont la
petite patrie vers le temps de bureau
j'ai plongé par 1 à 20 elle raconte
comment il a fait une chute en 2016
incapable de se relever ou d'atteindre
au téléphone et les rester par terre
pendant près de quarante quatre heures
sans eau sans nourriture
ça n'a pas trop peu peau on peut pas
demander de l'aïe parce que au fur et à
mesure où j'étais je tenais déshydraté
j'ai perdu la voix une auxiliaire qui se
rend chez elle une fois par semaine la
découverte est tendue dans le salon elle
a aussitôt appelé les secours
deux ans plus tard madame pigeon laisse
des téléphones au sol pour se sentir en
sécurité
s'il y avait eu le programme pair tout
aurait été enclenché puis j'aurai je
serai jamais été dans mon frotter
dessous le programme pair c'est un
service d'appels automatisés qui joint
les aînés tous les jours
si l'abonné ne répond pas le service
alerte un proche ou ultime en la police
c'est un service qui sauve des dizaines
de vies par année mais qui est
inaccessible dans la plupart des
secteurs de montréal dont celui où
habite madame pigeon était la première
fois comment comment parler aujourd'hui
alors une fois que j'entends ça je me
dis bah t'es con plus justement faire
des liens avec les organismes sur un
extérieur ça va être la municipalité
souvent les services de police ou le
centre d'action bénévole local qui vont
lever la main qui dit j'aimerais offrir
ce service non seulement 6000 personnes
sont abonnées au québec qui elles vivent
surtout en région mais l'objectif est
d'atteindre 100 mille abonnés d'ici
trois ans ce à quoi la nouvelle ministre
responsable des aînés se dit favorable
dans une déclaration écrite
marguerite blais promettent de bonifier
les budgets pour le maintien à domicile
est dit considérer l'utilisation
d'appels automatisés que cet engagement
soit respectée c'est l'unique suède de
lys pigeons pour 2019 ici sébastien
desrosiers radio-canada mourir